one of the
things that garnered a lot of excitement
in the crypto community
is nfts i i have no idea
really the depths the fundamental
technological philosophical
depths of the second of this technology
whether this is just like a little bit
of a fad or there's some deep lessons to
learn whether it's bitcoin or
cryptocurrency in general about it
do you have thoughts about like the long
lasting fundamental aspects of nfts
i think there's probably both things
happening fad
and things to learn right and um
if we just start with like what is an
nft it's a non-fungible token
meaning that um there's no fungibility
and fungibility is a
fancy word um i always describe it as if
i took a hundred dollar bill and i put
it on the table with a bunch of other
hundred dollar bills and we mixed them
up and i just grabbed a hundred dollar
bill and left
i'm no worse as long as they're all you
know uh official hundred dollar bills
because as long as i have 100 100 i
don't need that exact same bill back so
that means that those hundred dollar
bills are fungible
non-fungible would be like art if i took
a picasso and i put it down on the table
and you brought three artists that no
one's ever heard of before and we mixed
them up
and i just took any random piece of art
and it wasn't the picasso i lose because
the picasso is really important there
right so the non-fungibility is
important in art
what these non-fungible tokens
essentially are doing is they are
creating scarcity and originality
in a digital environment and what i mean
by that is
um take a music file if i had a music
file
and you wanted it you said send it to me
i press send it essentially creates a
copy
and you get one music file i get another
we don't care you can listen to music i
can listen to music we're super happy
if i instead though have a digital file
that
entire premise is based on scarcity
and i hit send and you get a copy and i
keep the original or you get the
original i get a copy
there's a problem and so ultimately
what i think is playing out with nfts is
it's a technology
regardless of where it plays out from
blockchains or
what in communities or environments that
just
brings true digital scarcity to the
internet
and so naturally what do people do they
look at the legacy world and they say
well what's scarce there that has value
how do we bring that to the digital
world so art is a perfect example right
and
you know frankly last year i started to
look at this because it felt like this
was going to be really really big
and the conclusion i came to was
just as bitcoin is going to be bigger
than gold right the
digital application of something is
going to be bigger than the analog
application
the same thing's going to be true in art
the digital art world is even bigger
than the nutritional art world
people think that sounds crazy at first
until you start to realize
it's very very similar the yard is more
portable
it can be divisible right it's got a
larger demand market in terms of the
internet rather than an
auction right all this kind of stuff
when you display it
it can have motion and music and all of
these aspects to it that are better than
the traditional art
what the traditional art market has that
the digital art market has not had
is the narrative narrative-based world
scarcity kind of a digital uh sense
and so what i think the entire world is
going through right now
is an exploration of how do we use this
technology
to create new things
frankly we're not gonna be good at it
for a while and so
the only place i've really focused on is
digital art itself
and i've always been interested in art
but i wasn't gonna go buy a painting and
hang it on the wall
right in the sense of that's how i was
going to store value
what i find fascinating though is that i
now can take
that concept which most of the
wealthiest people in the world
have a significant portion some you know
some people have 20 in terms of you know
number of billionaires
20 of their wealth is in art and you can
bring to this digital realm which is
much more
um kind of natural to a digital native
and so the best way to describe the
importance is
imagine a serial number being placed on
something
take the eiffel tower the only eiffel
tower that has value is the first one
every replica of it regardless of size
location
you know who made it where they sent it
they have no value eiffel tower zero
zero one is the most important
and so i think that's ultimately what
we're starting to see here
and what we're looking at is probably
one percent of what it's going to grow
into
who yeah you're bullish on you're saying
it could grow into something for
one percent it could grow into something
significant like all kinds of different
applications
strip away all the applications right
now and just think about
is digital scarcity going to be
important on the internet right moving
all the things that are scarce in the
physical world into digital space
us trying to figure out which things can
be moved and not and also there's things
in the digital space just like you're
saying that don't exist in the physical
world that might
also benefit from gaining scarcity like
you know people are i guess creating
nfts out of like tweets
or whatever so like you're you have you
have a fun twitter account
you know you could say like you could
put value to a single tweet and then be
able to invest in it and trade it and
buy parts of it and all those kinds of
things you know you can invest in people
you can invest in
you know art can be defined broadly as
any kind of creation right in in some
sense
this whole idea of scarcity
can overtake the entirety of the digital
world
it can like consume the
all of the markets we see as financial
markets and just turn everything into a
market
you